this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Shopify my trusted
partner for merch sales on July 19th
2012 the Solar Dynamics Observatory
captured this incredible footage of the
Sun this clip was recorded with one
frame every 12 seconds meaning every
second of this video represents six
minutes of real time this event began
with an intense solar flare a sudden
release of magnetic energy sending
ungodly amounts of energy in the form of
radiation and light into space this
particular solar flare was followed by a
coronal mass ejection a massive twisted
bubble shaped eruption firing a colossal
cloud of electrically charged particles
into space which can disrupt
interplanetary magnetic fields and
interact with Earth's magnetic field in
what is known as a geomagnetic storm
finally as the solar storm subsided and
the eruption bubble began to cool
we were treated to one of the most
mesmerizing events in our solar system
coronal rain where the remaining charged
plasma cools and falls back to the
surface of the Sun forming these
beautiful cage-like structures as the
particles follow the sun's magnetic
field lines back down an astounded ly
beautiful event but had it happened just
a week earlier the flare would have been
pointing squarely at earth and it
wouldn't have been the first time a
solar storm affected life negatively on
earth in 1859 a similarly powerful solar
flare called the Carrington event did
hit earth treating people as far south
as the Caribbean to the Northern Lights
while also knocking out major telegraph
systems in both Europe and North America
in some cases the geomagnetic
disturbances were so strong that they
sparked fires shocked telegraph
operators and even allowed the telegraph
system to work with no power in 1989 a
large geomagnetic storm caused a
blackout in Quebec after the coronal
mass ejection managed to trip circuit
breakers in the grid leaving six million
people without power for nine
hours so clearly these storms have the
power to really mess with vital
technologies that keep our society
moving but how exactly do they do it to
understand this we first need to
understand some basics of how
electricity is generated in our power
stations as you probably know already we
generate electricity by moving a wire
through a magnetic field or vice versa
the basic law behind this is called
Faraday's law which states that any
change to a magnetic field surrounding a
coil of wire will cause an
electro-motive force to be produced
otherwise known as a voltage the voltage
can be considered the force pushing the
electrons through a wire if they are
free to move a current will be produced
the current is a measure of the rate of
flow of electrons we generally generate
electricity by rotating a coil of wire
inside in magnetic field we do it this
way simply because rotational motion is
efficient with no changing of Direction
like linear motion forcing us to
decelerate and loosen ershon but we can
generate currents other ways like
dropping a magnet through a coil of wire
this moves the magnetic field itself
rather than the coil of wire so
stationary wires can generate currents
when a magnetic field changes around
them and our electricity grid happens to
be made up of millions of kilometres of
stationary wire we have effectively
turned the planet into a massive
electric generator by surrounding the
Earth's magnetic core with all this
conductive wire the only thing that's
missing is a large shift in the Earth's
magnetic field unfortunately for us
that is exactly what coronal mass
ejections do to Earth's magnetic field
on March 10th 1989 the Sun blasted a
cloud of charged particles so large that
it wore our planet in size it raced
through space at 450 kilometres per
second before crashing into the Earth's
magnetic poles the boundary between
Earth's magnetosphere and interplanetary
space sitting about 65 thousand
kilometers above Earth it struck with
such force that it literally shook and
trembled our planet's protective
magnetic field the first phase of this
is called the sudden storm commencement
where the coronal mass
first arrives at our Magneto pause
causing the magneto sphere to compress
on the daylight side of the earth
resulting in a sudden increase in the
intensity of the geomagnetic field in
that region the next phase results in a
decrease in intensity as an electric
current induced in the magnetosphere and
ionosphere pushes the boundary of the
magneto sphere outwards and results in a
decrease in the geomagnetic field and
the geomagnetic field can continue to
vary from hours to days after this
initial burst
so these geomagnetic storms cause shifts
in the Earth's magnetic field which
drives induced electric currents in
anything capable of carrying them that
can be the ground ocean or our
electricity grid
if those currents enter our grid they
can wreak havoc on essential
infrastructure so it seems like a
disaster is waiting to happen what are
we doing to prepare for the worst
unsurprisingly one of the largest
industries on earth has taught pretty
hard about this problem and has set out
guidelines on how to deal with such an
event as mentioned in my recent solar
sailing video we currently have several
satellites parked in LaGrange point one
a point between the Sun and the earth
where a satellite can maintain a
constant position and thus allow us to
receive advanced warning of any coronal
mass ejection this point confused many
commenters who assumed solar flares who
were simply bursts of radiation
traveling at the speed of light and thus
no speed of light communication method
could give us advance warning but these
eruptions of particles travel at a
fraction of the speed of light about
0.15 percent the speed of light for our
above 1989 event and thus can provide up
to an hour of warning time we also have
some less definitive warning signs that
the Sun may Point a coronal mass
ejection in our direction by observing
sunspots which are dips in brightness on
the surface of the Sun which occur as
magnetic energy bottles up in the solar
atmosphere before being suddenly
released these sunspots come in cycles
of low and high activity every 11 years
this warning time can provide grid
operators a little
to prepare for any anomalies but they
are more useful for GPS satellites whose
accuracy is affected by ionosphere
disturbances as their radio waves
refract through it and thus need to
adjust their signal to compensate force
in severe solar storms these warnings
would give industries where GPS
malfunction could lead to loss of life
like airliners vital time to prepare to
protect our grid it's really a matter of
designing it in a way to be able to deal
with these induced currents let's take a
deeper look into that 1989 blackout to
see what really happened and see how
grid operators can prepare the first
malfunction occurred as a result of
transformers becoming saturated power
transformers are placed at intervals
between high-voltage transmission lines
and power generators or local
distribution lines to step up or step
down voltages so what is saturation mean
transformers work by winding wire from
the source around a ferromagnetic core
this generates a magnetic field inside
the core which can in turn induce an
electric current in our secondary
winding if our primary wire has more
windings than the secondary wire it will
step down the voltage and if the
secondary wire has more windings to the
primary wire it will step up the voltage
these transformers form an essential
part of our grid but when the core
becomes saturated it interferes with
their operation saturation just means
that the magnetic core has reached its
maximum magnetic flux capabilities so an
increase in current and voltage will not
result in a subsequent increase of
magnetic flux if this happens the
voltage induced in the secondary winding
can no longer match the wave form as the
voltage powering the primary coil so the
wave form of the secondary wire becomes
distorted when this happened in Quebec
the grid voltage became unstable causing
the protective relays to disconnect five
high voltage transmission lines
including one from a hydroelectric
facility as the hydroelectric facility
was disconnected it experienced a rapid
loss of load meaning its power had
nowhere to go which caused the voltage
to suddenly increase which damaged two
step-up transformers as a result of
excessive heating
saturated transformers are the root
cause of most great malfunctions during
magnetic storms
however in 1989 the knock-on effect of
these waveform distortions is what
caused the majority of the damage as
electromechanical protective relays
tripped and cut off sections of the grid
electromechanical relays are essentially
switches that turn on and off when
electric current flows in the control
circuit creating a magnetic field in an
electromagnet and pulls an armature down
to complete a circuit in a secondary
circuit these can be combined to form
logic gates that are more complicated
but are in general not programmable to
deal with anomalies like distorted
waveforms caused by transformer
saturation today we have much smarter
microprocessor technology that can be
programmed to deal with these issues
better and maintain grid stability but
because of the electromechanical relays
reliability and long service life there
are still thousands of these older
devices in the grid infrastructure but
they are slowly being phased out for
more modern technology especially in
northern and southern regions more
susceptible to Geo magnetically induced
currents we can also block geomagnetic
lee induced currents because they are
direct currents where our normal power
is alternating current capacitors can
only transmit alternating current
because capacitors don't physically
complete circuits they are just a large
stores of positive and negative
potentials that switch every time the
current flips DC currents don't flip and
thus capacitors do not allow DC currents
to flow so we do have options to
minimize the effects of these
disturbances I expected this to be a
dramatic video that would drag viewers
in on the fear of their grid failing
from solar flares you can probably tell
from the shift in tone from the start of
the video to the end as I researched
this topic more thoroughly it really
seems like mainstream media's
fear-mongering on the effects of solar
storms on our electricity grid is
completely overblown with only one
notable blackout caused by geomagnetic
aliy induced currents that were today's
technology was completely preventable
there isn't much evidence that grid
operators need to spend vast amounts of
money on these systems although DC
blocking
our systems have been installed in
countries in northern locations more at
risk of geomagnetic disturbances like
Finland and England in the end the only
recent electricity grid operators have
not implemented these DC blocking
devices and other mitigating
technologies is because they would cost
more to model and implement than the
risk geomagnetic disturbances actually
posed to the grid in reality the risk
from hurricanes and other terrestrial
weather events pose a much bigger risk
to our electricity grid the electricity
grid makes the internet possible and the
Internet has changed the world in almost
every way possible including allowing
people to start and run entire
businesses without ever leaving their
homes reaching customers all over the
world I am able to sell my graph paper
notebooks t-shirts and pins with the
help of Shopify who have all the tools
you need to set up an online store if
you want to start your own online
selling business Shopify is the perfect
place to start
it has logo generators plug-and-play
themes so you can make your page look
professional with zero coding experience
has the tools to organize ad campaigns
and analytics to analyze your success it
was crazy to see my analytics spike last
month when I announced the graph paper
notebook with over 2000 sold so far and
only a fraction of that left in stock
Shopify makes selling easy with easy
integration of multiple payment options
and as 24/7 customer support should you
need it if you want to set up that side
hustle right now
you can try it out for free for 14 days
by going to Shopify calm for it slash
real engineering as always thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
you